>>> A RAPID TRANSFORMATION OF
THE BATTLEFIELD IN EASTERN
UKRAINE, UKRNIAN FORCES ROLLED
THROUGH LINES OF RUSSIAN
DEFENSES AND RECAPTURED MORE
THAN 3,000 SQUARE KILOMETERS OF
TERRITORY.
YOU'RE SEEING RIGHT NOW SOME
TROOPS, I THINK UKRAINIAN TROOPS
IN AREAS THEY'VE RETAKEN.
JOINING ME NOW IS RETIRED ARMY
MAJOR MIKE LYONS.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE AREA
THEY'VE TAKEN BACK.
EVERYWHERE YOU SEE IN YELLOW
THERE IS TERRITORY THE
UKRAINIANS HAVE TAKEN BACK VERY
RECENTLY.
I WANT TO PUSH IN SO WE CAN GET
A BETTER LOOK.
THIS AREA IN YELLOW PART OF THIS
NEW UKRAINIAN COUNTER OFFENSIVE,
HOW HAVE THE UKRAINIANS BEEN
ABLE TO DO THIS AND WHAT'S THE
SIGNIFICANCE?
>> OVER A THOUSAND SQUARE MILES,
AREAS LOST SINCE FEBRUARY BUT
ABLE TO BE GAINED BACK.
THE KEY AREA IS THE CONTROL,
THEY BROUGHT TROOPS IN FROM THIS
DIRECTION AND THIS DIRECTION.
THEY WERE ABLE TO CHASE THE
RUSSIAN MILITARY ACROSS THE
RIVER HERE ON THE OTHER SIDE, ON
THE EASTERN SIDE OF THE RIVER.
A LOT HAS TO DO WITH ARTILLERY.
THEY'RE ABLE TO CHASE THE
RUSSIAN MILITARY WELL PAST THE
RIVER, GIVING THEM THAT
ADVANTAGE ON THEIR SIDE OF THE
RIVER.
>> IF WE PULL OUT AGAIN AND LOOK
AT THE AREA, HOW MUCH FURTHER DO
YOU THINK THEY CAN PUSH THIS AND
WHAT WILL THIS DEPEND ON?
>> UKRAINE HAS THE INITIATIVE,
YOU LOOK AT THE RUSSIAN MILITARY
THERE IN ALMOST FULL RETREAT.
UNEATEN FOOD, THAT TO ME IS A
BAD SIDE WHEN A MILITARY DOES
THAT.
THE QUESTION IS, THE MILITARY
CAN'T OUTRUN THEIR SUPPLY LINES
AS WELL.
SO IF RUSSIA NOW GOES AND
REINFORCES DOWN TO THE SOUTH,
THEN ALL THAT THE UKRAINE CAN DO
IS HOLD THAT AREA.
I THINK THAT WOULD BE A WIN AND
THAT WOULD BE GOOD ENOUGH FOR
NOW.
>> I WANT TO ASK BECAUSE A LOT
OF THE FOCUS -- UKRAINE HAD BEEN
SAYING THEY WERE STAGING THIS
COUNTEROFFENSIVE WE THOUGHT IT
WOULD HAPPEN IN THE SOUTH NEAR
KHE
KHERSON.
DOES THAT APPEAR TO BE A FAINT
TO DRAW THE RUSSIAN'S ATTENTION
TO ATTACK UP HERE INSTEAD?
>> I THINK THE UKRAINE MILITARY
WAS ABLE TO CONVINCE RUSSIA
THAT'S WHERE THE MAIN BATTLE WAS
GOING TO BE.
BUT UKRAINE WANTED A VICTORY AND
THEY KNEW THEY COULD GET ONE IN
THE NORTH HERE.
I THINK CLASSIC ECONOMY FORCE
MISSION.
HOLD THE SHOULDER HERE TO MAKE
SURE THEY DON'T LOSE THAT AREA
WHILE THEY HAVE THE
COUNTEROFFENSIVE TO THE NORTH.
A LOT OF THE ABILITY TO DO THIS
IS THE WESTERN EQUIPMENT.
>> AND WE'RE TALKING 30, 40
MILES A DAY THEY'RE RETAKING.
WHICH IS SOMETHING THE RUSSIANS
WERE ONLY ABLE TO DO THE
BEGINNING OF THIS CONFLICT.
SO THIS IS STILL A BATTLE OR
SERIES OF BATTLE.
AS WE TALK ABOUT LONG TERM WHAT
DOES THAT HINGE ON?
>> UKRAINE IS WINNING BUT
HAVEN'T WON.
A LOT HAS TO DO WITH THE WAY
BATTLES GO.
ONCE WE WIN THIS, THE WAR WILL
BE OVER QUICKLY.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S THE CASE.
THIS IS NOW A PEOPLE'S WAR.
YOU'RE SEEING WAR OF ATTRITION
TAKING PLACE ON BOTH SIDES.
THIS IS GOING TO COME DOWN TO
INDUSTRIAL STRENGTH.
WHICH SIDE HAS MORE INDUSTRIAL
POWER.
IF UKRAINE LOSES THE SUPPORT OF
WESTERN ALLIES THEN I'M AFRAID
RUSSIA HAS MORE INDUSTRIAL POWER
THEY CAN WIN THE WAR BUT RIGHT
NOW THE BATTLES ARE GOING TO
CRANE.
>> UKRAINE.
>> IT'S POLITICAL.
CAN THE UKRAINIANS PUSH FORWARD
AND RETAKE MORE TERRITORY.
>> THERE'S OBSTACLES HERE.
RIVER OBSTACLES THAT RUSSIA IS
NOW ON THE DEFENSIVE, UKRAINE
WILL HAVE TO HAVE MORE MEN AND
MATERIAL.
WE KNOW UKRAINE HAS SUFFERED
CASUALTIES HERE.
THE QUESTION IS HOW WILL THEY BE
ABLE TO NEGOTIATE THOSE
OBSTACLES AND THE ARTILLERY AND
THE WEAPONS SYSTEMS WE HAVE WILL
PUT THE RUSSIAN MILITARY MORE ON
THEIR HEELS MUCH FURTHER BACK.
IT'S A WIN FOR THEM TO HOLD THE
LINE.
>> RIGHT AT THE RIVER WHERE THEY
ARE RIGHT NOW.
>> YES.
>> ALWAYS GREAT TO SEE YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.